hey guys some of you asked me Daniel
what's your thoughts on Andrew tight
hmm
well there's a lot of things that's
going through my head at the moment but
for some of you who do not know who he
is
check out this first
I have seen so many women fail to park
and crash cars and do duck I do not want
a female pilot flying me through a
hurricane there's anti-woman diatribes
often going viral I've seen enough
female driving of all vehicles to know
that that is a bad idea that's a
fundamental tenet of the male
supremacist doctrine that women are a
second class to men former kickboxer and
Big Brother contestant Andrew Tate
Infamous for being the self-proclaimed
king of toxic masculinity man can only
cheat if he loves someone else if I have
a woman who I truly love and I go out
and I come back to her and I don't care
about her and I only love my girl that's
not cheating that's exercise if she even
talks to a dude is cheating we had to
practice if a girl comes at you how are
you cheater you're cheating It's banging
out the machete boom in her face and
grip her up by the neck
before the hustlers Academy little is
known about how Tate made his money he
and his brother had a pornographic
webcam business in their hometown of
Luton since 2012.
after he moved to Romania in 2017 he set
up a number of Darker businesses
including casinos and another webcam
operation that is at the center of this
police investigation Tristan Tate has
openly described the webcam business as
a scam in which young women dupe men
into handing over money The Matrix has
attacked me he's called himself the king
of toxic masculinity but now
controversial influencer Andrew Tate has
been arrested in Romania Andrew Tates a
former kickboxer he's now a social media
influencer last year he was more Google
than Donald Trump or Kim Kardashian and
his contents amassed hundreds of
millions of views his enthusiasm for
misogyny cars and wealth has delivered
Fame thousands of fans and many
thousands of dollars
uh well I think Andrew Tate was uh and
his team are quite quite aware of the
fact that any publicity even bad
publicity would help them and that was
perhaps one of the reasons they decided
to to let us in I think what they didn't
realize was that we were also
simultaneously doing an investigation
into him that ultimately led to us
speaking to for the first time some of
the women from his past who allege that
he raped and abused them now that was
just a quick introduction and just so
you know I don't really trust all news
sources
and uh I don't know Android site
personally right so I cannot really
judge him because I've never met him but
I can only try to judge him righteously
by looking at what he himself has said
on social media
and some of you also know that he's been
recently arrested for for what for sex
trafficking and for rape influencer and
angled tights Angels girlfriend
Georgiana Nagel and glamorous former cop
Luana Radu along with his kickboxer
brother Tristan heavily armed police
broke down the door of his compound in
Bucharest on Thursday night as part of a
rape and human trafficking investigation
mail online has spent years tracking the
activities of Tate and talking to his
relatives but many questions remain now
when he was arrested he said something
interesting he said the Matrix attacked
him the Matrix has attacked me I know a
lot of people said that he's innocent
and a lot of people say he's guilty I'm
not going to jump on this wagon but it
is interesting to look at his past as
well something interesting that happened
in 2016 Tate was cast on the British
version of Big Brother who was kicked
off the show after only five days
according to a report from Vice Big
Brother's producers removed tape from
the show Once they learned he was under
investigation for rape Tate was never
charged after Big Brother Tate started
to build his online Empire and a webcam
business where he paid women to perform
on camera take claimed the business once
earned six hundred thousand dollars a
month success is actually
actually good at your job
well no that probably depends on what
you mean by success because different
people view success differently as will
become clear as we continue in this
video now let's do this to tell you what
I really think about Andrew Tate I need
to do so righteously
a lot of people say well Daniel you
can't judge right the Bible says you
shouldn't judge and you're a Christian
well that's not exactly what the Bible
says it says that we should not judge
wrongly and that we should look at
ourselves first
you know instead of costing a stone we
should first look at our own lives and
see if there's anything that we are
doing that's
the same or even worse and then if we
sorted that out then we can judge
righteously
and it says that we should judge
between right and wrong now the verse
they usually used and quote where they
say Hey you shouldn't judge people
that's what the Bible says
is Matthew 7 verse 1. it says judge not
that you be not judged
so they use this verse but they don't
read the rest of it listen to verse 4 it
says Aura how can you say to your
brother let me take this Speck out of
your eye
when there is the log in your own eye
you hypocrite first take the log out of
your own eye and then you will see
clearly to take the spec out of your
brother's eye
so when you want to judge someone who's
swearing but you do the same thing you
can't judge that person a lot of parents
do it right when their kids are swearing
that I don't swear but the parents are
the ones that's swearing the most you
can't do that you're a hypocrite
so sort yourself out first before you
want to tell someone else what to do and
then the Bible says that you have to
judge righteously between what is right
and what is wrong John 7 24 do not judge
by appearances but judge with right
judgment all right so let's do this I
believe a lot of people especially young
guys they like Andrew Tate because he
says things that others are too scared
of saying especially in the world that
we live in today
where people are fighting just for the
freedom of speech
I never thought that we would live in
this day and age but this is where we
are and so Andrew he's not afraid to say
what he thinks and what he believes and
he actually says stuff that I agree with
I wake up every day excited I'll go do
this today I'll go do this today I'm
gonna do this today and I very much live
my life in a frame of
not I have to do this it's very much I
get to do this there's another thing
that a lot of people make a mistake with
when I talk to them like ah I have to go
to work today change your language I get
to go to work today imagine you had no
job be worse right because otherwise you
wouldn't be working so you get to go to
work I have to fix the car at least you
have a car you get to fix your car most
people don't got one I have to go get
the kids you get to go get the kids
because you have these beautiful
children who love you he also says
things that I agree with where many to
be men and that men do certain jobs they
work really hard at certain jobs that
some women won't do just to provide for
their family I believe in marriage no
please I believe in marriage in the
traditional sense I believe a man has a
duty to stand up and be a real man I
believe that the problem with the world
today that we are facing is that not
enough men are sticking to the age-old
ways of masculinity I believe that me
standing up and saying a man must
protect a woman and provide for her so
he needs to make sure that she's safe he
needs a degree of authority I have no
problem with no but no you but people do
have a problem with it and that's not
sorry and that's the world we're in now
I'm over here sure I don't have a
problem with what you just said here's
where my problem comes right there are a
lot of clips of you floating around on
the internet as you know one of them has
you saying bang out the machetes see
boom in her face Ripper by the neck shut
up in another you say slap slap grab
choke shut up sex now the first part of
here I agree with being a real man and
protecting your family taking care of
the things that you need to do taking
responsibility right but man these other
vulgar comments that he made I don't
agree with at all
and then he's also right about
talking about all the craziness that's
in the world crazy people like evil
influencers we're and I'm not I'm
certainly not the worst influence out
here peers you have little Nas twerking
on the devil on music videos which our
children are digesting you have uh
drillar is singing about stabbing people
to death in the middle of a knife crime
epidemic you have rabid uh Psychopaths
on whether the right or the left
announcing violence on the other side
you have all these insanities in the
world now with that said I think he's
clever in the way where he knows how to
get views and so I think that he's
putting up a Persona acting rough and
tough and showing that a real man is
Rich has many cars
dates as many girls as he wants and is
arrogant and selfish
so he created this image of himself as a
toxic male and I think he did it on
purpose he also believes most of the
stuff that he says of course but he's
pushing it even harder because it
creates drama not just with what he says
but the way he says it and then drama
creates more views right now don't get
me wrong I'm all for masculinity
but not for toxic masculinity I believe
that men should be men
real men men of good character good
values and fighting for what is Right
protecting their families all of those
things I agree of 100 percent
but Andrew is mixing the good with the
bad
and The Ugly
and he's doing it to create drama this
is a very serious point because the
Western world has collapsed in real time
and it's a failed Society one of the
reasons is a failed Society is because
of the over sexualization especially
females as a whole I agree certain
people in power positions with an evil
agenda is pushing sex
on everyone on civilization they're
doing it through
well first of all they have a lot of
money and a lot of power right so evil
corporations you have the median you
have entertainment especially
entertainment because we're a society
that are addicted to entertainment so
what's the result when you look at these
last few decades more and more and more
and more sex everywhere you look
you have
men who grow up not understanding what
the true meaning of sex is and they
think that they are weird and strange if
they are still virgins at the age of 15
16 which leads a lot of people to have
unprotected sex and
children if there's a kid coming then
you just run away so you have these men
who just want to have sex women as well
but then there there's a kid who's
growing up without a father because the
father runs away and so you have these
broken families and the more you have of
them you have broken societies
and it's mostly because of us men a lot
of men out there who don't want to take
responsibility for their actions because
they're only led by their fleshly sinful
desires just want to have sex and it
causes a lot of pain and suffering in
the world
now listen to what Andrew does listen
how he spins this into the Bad and the
Ugly if a woman comes up to me and goes
I'll be the best sex you ever had I
bolted I don't want the best sex I've
ever had I want you to be pure and a
virgin you shouldn't know what sex is
shut up don't come and talk to me about
file it's disgusting
what I want is a woman that makes me
look good
all right number one I think I find it
really hard to listen to people who cuss
a lot because I I really do have less
respect for people who cuss because if
you think that you need to use cuss or
swear words to enhance your speech
because you don't feel that your speech
is good enough on its own or you are
good enough
then he's actually sad a lot of people
are using it for crutch words but also
people think that their normal speech is
not good enough
and I want to sound cooler and better
but it doesn't make you cooler better
it is not only wrong it is vulgar
and you shouldn't do it you should have
some self-respect be a man of character
a man of value the Bible says in
Ephesians 4 29 do not let unwholesome
foul profane worthless vulgar words ever
come out of your mouth but only such
speech as is good for building up others
according to the need and the occasion
so that it will be a blessing to those
who hear you speak now just about the
other comments that Andrew Made In that
clip
I believe a lot of men would like to
marry a virgin right and it's exactly
the same the other way around women
would like to marry a virgin
and the Bible says that you shouldn't
have sex outside of marriage and that
includes before marriage and that used
to be the dominant view in society by
the entertainment industry changed it
the media changed it Hebrews 13 verse 4.
let marriage be held in honor among all
and let the marriage bed be undefiled
for God will judge the sexually immoral
and adulteress for you young men out
there if you want to listen to the world
and act like the world then you will
have divorces like the rest of the world
when you look at society today even
celebrities you know you think that they
would have it all all the successes work
this world could offer them Fame
money
success and then
they're not happy
then you'll be one of those people who
just wants antidepressants all the time
just to take you out of reality because
you want to escape you can't deal with
the normal world anymore that's because
of the decisions that you make and the
things that you believe that's part of
this world
don't think it's cool to sleep as
much as you can with as many women as
you can because it creates a lot of
problems and those problems will follow
you for the rest of your life especially
when you finally find the woman that you
really love
you bring all those experiences and that
baggage with you into the marriage and
it can create a lot of problems and it
does create a lot of problems for a lot
of men and women
now watch this this is one percent of
men have created this terrible Society
yeah I talk about that I talk about the
Matrix I talk about these things but
it's always been this way it's always
been a small Elite group of men who are
in charge of the world and unfortunately
now we're fighting battles in different
ways the the days of old a man proved
his worth by going to war basically
every man at any point in his life was
going to end up going to war and he came
back Victorious he came back with honor
he got himself a wife that's that's how
it worked right now men don't have to go
to war as much depending on where you
live in the world and it's slightly
different and we fight our Wars in other
ways and one of the true expressions of
testosterone and trying to really
express your ability and your combative
ability now in the in the modern world
is power and influence so in the olden
days you go to war you come back with a
ribbon nowadays you go x amount of
followers you can move the world with
money I can bend reality with money
please understand if I walk into Jimmy
Choo they lock the door no broke he's
allowed in Tate's here I want there's
lines outside because I'm there first a
lot of men still go to war but they
don't need to go to war to prove their
worth especially if you're a man of
character then you know
you don't need to prove your Worth to
anyone because you already know your
worth
second running after money and power is
easy for a man because that's what your
sinful flesh want to do and he wants to
brag about it like Andrew but a real man
does not want Power fame or gain the
whole world in this short temporary life
because he knows it won't profit him if
he loses his soul in the end for all
eternity
because he sees the bigger picture of
life he fights to overcome evil with
good he wants to take care of his family
provide and protect because he knows
that a real battle is not against other
people against flesh it's against evil
itself evil pulling the strings behind
the scenes Ephesians 6 12 says for we do
not wrestle against the flesh and blood
but against the rulers against the
authorities against the cosmic Powers
over this present Darkness against the
spiritual forces of evil in the Heavenly
places
so when it comes to Andrew I think he's
he's clever in the wrong way his
strategy is to start out good and to say
something that is truthful but then he
makes the wrong conclusion sometimes
he's right sometimes he's wrong but he's
he's doing it and he's also saying it in
a way that will just create drama
I agree with what Ben Shapiro said I
like Andrew Tate got such traction yes
so what I've said about Andrew Tate is
that I would say that 75 of Andrew
Tate's diagnoses of the problem are
pretty correct yeah I agree and then I
would say that a lot of his
prescriptions are completely wrong yeah
right so he will he will say men have
lost their role in the world and then
what he will model is cam girls it's
like well that's not actually the
solution but what you're saying about
the problem of men losing their role and
Men needing to be masculine and Men
needing to want to win and Men needing
to cultivate an ability to to go out and
succeed and thrive in the world all of
that is 100 true I just think that he
himself on a personal level wasn't
providing a model of that to me a model
of that is a guy who is married who has
kids who lives in the community who
betters the community lives in who hires
people creates a business like these are
the things that historically speaking
did Define manhood and now they no
longer Define manhood men I think that
you can shot at the moment of
deterioration for the moment James Bond
started crying so it's not just what
Andrew tight says it's the way he says
it and he's doing it purposefully to
rile people up you know to shock them
and to create that drama just to get the
views even if it's true
some of the things that he says he still
knows if he says he's this way and first
he gets them and they agree and then he
says something that just kind of shocks
them and then rile them up and then
create drama see this there's not a girl
on this panel or on the planet today who
couldn't walk outside and find a man
who's gonna be nice to her loyal to her
and make her his Queen I agree but now
look at how he changes it up women don't
want that so they'll sit there and go no
I want Chris Brown and then they'll go
try to get Chris Brown then Chris Brown
will cheat and they'll be like I can't
believe he cheated I am devastated
I think it's gonna happen yeah a lot of
women especially young women go for bad
guys
especially if they don't understand what
the difference is between arrogance and
confidence because there is a line but I
don't understand it yet
and uh we also need to remember that all
women are not the same old men are not
the same and it's also the other way
around a lot of men fall for the wrong
woman and that messes up their lives as
well but now look how Andrew uses this
and turns it around to try and justify
his own sinful
desires to cheat and it's kind of going
to a car dealership you walk in there
you if you want reliability you can get
in this sand but if you want to get
Ferrari it comes with it comes with
headaches it's going to come with
problems so when girls say to me oh you
know what Andrew you know you should be
loyal to men like me don't have to be
the conclusion he's making is not just
wrong it is dangerous if a lot of men in
the world live this way we would have a
lot more broken families
which of course as I always say lead to
what
broken societies
and when you look at the world today we
are a whole we just we are a mess
because of it and then he Compares
himself to a Ferrari
in other videos to an alpha male
and you know here's the strangest thing
about people who do this it is usually
the type of men
who feel the need that they need to tell
other people how great they are who are
the most insecure Real Men of character
no they don't need to say anything they
never boast about themselves and their
actions speak for themselves they never
say anything
instead they would
boost other people up and build them up
and put the focus on them
that's a real man James 4 16. as it is
you boast in your arrogance all such
boasting is evil
and Paul said in 2 Corinthians 11 30. if
I must boast I will boast of the things
that show my weakness
why weakness
you know the older I get the more I
realize you know there's still so much
that I can learn about life I don't have
it all you know
so the more you really grow in wisdom
the more you understand how big this
world is and how small you really are
and so you understand how weak we are as
human beings and that makes you powerful
actually with that knowledge but if you
identify your own weaknesses when you
listen to other people other successful
people men who have good character and
good values if you learn from them you
grow as a person you start to look at
life differently the more you grow the
more you realize there's still so much
that you can learn of life and living
life this way understanding your own
weaknesses and and how to change it and
live differently makes you more powerful
listen elevating yourself in your own
mind oh I'm a Ferrari based on what your
sinful flesh wants to believe and no
facts but you're just doing it you know
it's pathetic it's based on what your
sinful flesh wants to believe and you're
just giving into it our sinful flesh
mine included is pathetic
we are led by our emotions a lot of
people are who are led by their sinful
desires and they give in and they
they're given by trying to rationalize
their emotions like Andrew Tay does in
the end in this example he's just using
excuses so that he can cheat
giving in to his sinful flesh he's
urges
and that's just what an animal does it's
easy to do that
but a real man has self-control a real
man has character lives by good values
and morals
1 Corinthians 7 verse 2 says but because
of the temptation to sexual immorality
each man should have his own wife
and each woman her own husband
his own wife not another woman someone
else's wife your own wife
now I want you to watch this because I
have
a lot of concerns with this tax is also
another important element of controlling
your woman you're not going to pay
anybody tax because you're getting paid
in Bitcoin so you don't need to pay tax
to anybody tell your girl
that you're paying the tax because girls
are lazy girl's stupid and girls don't
understand how taxes work so the girls
working with you and you're like oh okay
yeah we made this much money but I'm
gonna pay the tax to make sure we don't
get in trouble
she'll sit there go okay okay now that
allows you to do two things one is
another control element I work with him
my tax is not a problem if I do it alone
I have to deal with taxes taxes are
complicated so I have to pay my bill 30
percent
so for every ten thousand dollars they
made I give them three and I keep seven
they thought they were on fifty percent
and I said that the disparity was
because of taxes so you're on fifty
percent we had to pay the tax first and
then it's 50 50. so really you're paying
30 you tell them you're paying 50
difference is in the tax
that's where the disparity lies taxes
if you they don't believe you they want
to get fresh or whatever print out some
tax forms I see this all the time is to
print out some random tax forms so yeah
sign here and sign this what is it for
the tax you want to pay the tax or not
okay and they just sign away signing
let's throw them away they think
something's happening something real is
happening nothing's happening he's
teaching men to control their woman and
not to pay taxes are you kidding me
Jesus said in Mark 12 17 render to
Caesar the things that are Caesars and
to God the things that are gods
so he says that you should control your
women
I mean who Do You Think You Are
and he uses the Bible a lot sometimes
and he uses versus out of context wrong
then people believe him because they
don't read their Bibles
but the Bible is clear it doesn't say
you're the boss it says that you're a
leader there's a difference between a
leader and a boss you're the leader of
the home
treat your wife like a queen
and she will treat you like a king
control her like a tyrant and she will
hate you
the Bible actually says if you don't
treat your wife the right way your
prayers will be hindered
this is how serious this is to God 1
Peter 3 7 likewise husbands live with
your wives in an understanding way
showing honor to the woman as the weaker
vessel since they are heirs with you of
the grace of life so that your prayers
may not be hindered
now I agree with a lot of things that
Andrew says for example that there are
evil Elites who want to control the
world that
men should be more masculine because we
should be men I will fight for
masculinity
but the right understanding of what it
means to be a man
I am on the side of truth no matter who
says it for example you should never
deny the truth
if the person who says it is someone
that you don't like
so that also goes the other way around
you should never just believe a lie
because you like the person who says it
no you should stand with the truth
Elvis Presley of all people said truth
is like the sun you can shut it out for
a time but it ain't going away
I also disagree with a lot of things
that Andrew says because it's just not
true
and the way he says it I also don't
agree of certain ways that he's
man he's giving off this this wrong idea
of what a man is by the way that he
talks sometimes as well being very
egotistical arrogant toxic and there is
not only wrong but it is extremely
dangerous
if he convinces thousands of guys out
there to believe this so end up with all
these chicks you're stuck in our house
sitting there bored completely in love
with me and of course they don't go out
they're not allowed out no no no you
don't go to the club with your friends
no you stay in the house you don't go
nowhere you know no restaurants no clubs
nothing but if you could make a woman be
loyal to you while not being loyal to
her then you would not be loyal to her
if a man's truly honest and says if I
can press this button and she's loyal to
me no matter what I do am I still gonna
only be with her now you might prefer
her you might spend 99 of your time with
her
Etc completely get that but on a long
enough time frame for the rest of your
human life if she's gonna be loyal to
you regardless are you telling me that
with a without any kind of backlash from
her without the chance of her cheating
that
you're going to tell me for the next 50
years you're not gonna anything ever
once if she let you why not like you
know what I mean yeah I mean I feel like
everyone would agree to that everyone
would agree to it right so if you show a
woman how to make a thousand dollars in
an hour she'll think I can work two
hours a week
if you show a man how to make a thousand
dollars in an hour he thinks I can make
18 000 a day
I am the ultimate Victor please
understand that there's no man on Earth
more powerful than me I mean I smoke
cigars but I know what I'm doing
give me a big fat cigar I'm risking
cancer to look like a Mafia Boss fine
when you see a man like me at three
o'clock on a Tuesday morning at a gas
station in a four hundred thousand
dollar sports car I get out the lambo
there's a big run I get out and putting
gas in do you look at me and go he
studied really hard in school or do you
look at me and think drug dealer
you think drug dealer because you
understand you must break the rules to
make money all right let's just stop
here he just said that if you think that
he's a drug dealer because of the car he
drives then you understand that rules
need to be broken meaning to achieve
success in this way you need to break
the rules laws
are you kidding me he's basically saying
to thousands of guys if you want to be
rich and successful
drive a nice car then you need to break
the law
there is so much wrong here I almost
don't even know
where to begin
but maybe the best way to explain to you
is by
yeah maybe talking to you about my
brother
Yono my eldest brother he was a great
guy who
unfortunately hang out with the wrong
friends and started to sell drugs he
changed him he wanted to live for the
world
my brother had a lot of money he had a
great car he looked cool you know he
came home one day even with a lot of
stuff on the truck
that he took from people who couldn't
pay him
now let me quickly ask you how many of
you were thinking about money success
cars and oh I want this
and how many of you
for a moment actually thought about the
people they've hurt
and I'm saying this about my own brother
I'm not defending him because he's my
brother I'm defending truth a lot of
people are destroying lives because of
their greed their desire for worldly
success
and it's causing so much pain and
suffering especially if we just look at
the drugs people getting addicted to
drugs selling a lot of stuff just so
they can get more drugs
pushing out family members and I mean
it's just so much pain
and suffering
and my brother is dead
he was in his early twenties
he had the world
and he died
the drug dealer who he worked for more
like the kingpender drug lord shot him
three times in the chest
and he's gone
Matthew 16 verse 25. for what will it
profit a man if he gains the whole world
wealth Fame success but forfeits his
soul
my brother is dead as we're speaking as
you're listening to this video his bones
are lying in a grave he had money he had
a nice house he had a car he had
everything that this world will think is
oh it's amazing
but he's dead none of that matters
when Andrew Tate dies none of his things
will matter when you die none of your
things will matter
what matters is how you live your life
before you die what matters is that my
brother two weeks before he died which
happened to be on my dad's birthday he
changed his life he went to God and he
repented of his sins he said I'm sorry
he started to realize what he was doing
he wanted to turn his life around he
said God he prayed with his friend
called Philip he said I want to I want
to change my life God please forgive me
for everything that I've done you've
always been there with me I pushed you
away but now I'm coming back to you I'm
knocking on your door that was two weeks
before he died
he wanted to flee to England and the
drug lord shot him
now from a worldly perspective that's
sad is oh no for me I'm grateful because
he's in heaven he's got eternal life
you see the real test of your short
existence here on Earth
is if you're going to choose the light
or the darkness
the easy path or the hard path it is
easy to choose the world and all its
Darkness because your sinful nature
wants to so it's easy to give in and be
controlled by your urges
it is hard to fight it and choose the
light
this temporary World goes by in an
instant and Andrew Tate says you
understand that you need to break the
law to achieve success and to be rich
I say that is exactly what is wrong with
this world people who break the law of
living selfishly not caring about other
people
who is causing this world to be what it
is right now causing so much pain and
suffering
Andrew says you gotta chase after
success even if you have to break the
law and control your woman like a tyrant
I say that it is better
to be a man of value than to be a man of
success because if you are a man of
value then that is actually what it
means to be really successful
Great Men of the past who made a name
for themselves who we remember today
we don't remember them for starting porn
sites and making quick Rich schemes and
grabbing women by the throat like what
Andrew Tate is doing no
that's not real men
is that what you want to be remembered
for
great men are being remembered for being
men of character men of value Abraham
Lincoln led the nation of America
through Civil War and abolished slavery
Martin Luther King the preacher inspired
by his Christian beliefs fought for
civil rights through non-violence
Jesus Christ the most famous of all gave
his life for all Humanity
you know if there's one example
of what it means to be a true man
that is Jesus Christ
even other great men who left their mark
on this world they said Jesus was
amazing
Albert Einstein considered one of the
most intelligent men to ever walked on
the earth he said this as a child I
received instruction both in the Bible
and in the talmud I am a Jew
but I am enthralled by the Luminous
figure of Jesus the Nazarene
and even Gandhi said a man who was
completely innocent offered himself as a
sacrifice for the good of others
including his enemies and became The
Ransom of the world
it was a perfect ACT
why Jesus why was he the perfect example
of a man
was he ruffed off and he was arrogant
and selfish He Walked on other people
and sacrificed their life so that he can
gain more money to be successful sold
drugs or
all right
listen
it was perfect he loved the perfect life
and showed us men how to be real men and
to live our lives righteously the right
way loving other people not being
selfish there's so much that we can talk
about when it comes to Jesus Christ my
small brain cannot even comprehend him
but he's the only person that changed my
life 100 percent
180 degrees I changed I used to be this
arrogant this selfish just like Andrew
Tate I used to be like him
and when my second brother died
everything changed I felt God speaking
to me in my spirit in my inner man
Daniel what are you doing with your life
wasting it
this is your second brother you could
have died where would you have gone
I can read the same things over and over
and I can't get enough I still grow from
it
Jesus is the only role model that I will
ever follow until the day I die because
he's got the power to change lives he
changed mine and he's still changing
lives today
Shalom asked polish-born essayist said
this Jesus Christ to me is the
outstanding personality of all time all
history both a Son of God and a son of
man everything he ever said or did has
value for us today
and that is something you can say of no
other man alive or dead
can't Leo Tolstoy Russian novelist and
philosopher
for 35 years of my life I was in the
proper acceptation of the word
nihilist a man who believed in nothing
five years ago my faith came to me I
believed in the doctrine of Jesus Christ
and my whole life underwent a sudden
transformation
French philosopher shall we suppose the
evangelic history a mere fiction indeed
my friend it bears not the marks of
fiction on the contrary the history of
Socrates which nobody presumes to doubt
is not so well attested as that of Jesus
Christ
Reynolds price American writer and Bible
scholar it would require much exotic
calculation however to deny that the
single most powerful figure not merely
in these two millenniums but in all
human history has been Jesus of Nazareth
young men if you want to know what a
true man is stop listening to crazy
weird people on social media
if you want a good role model an example
of the perfect man look at the life of
Jesus Christ grab a Bible and start
reading the New Testament for yourself
instead of listening to what other
people say
and it will change your life
maybe you're at a point in your life
where you need to make a decision where
you need to change your life
I want to ask you as someone who loves
you who cares about you don't choose the
darkness because nothing good will come
from it
you'll just go further down this deep
hole and we will bring a lot of pain and
suffering and at the end you'll lose
your soul for all eternity it is not
worth it I wish that I could just show
you what's in my my head all the
experiences I had all the truth that I
know that this is a reality
that you could just see the truth for
yourself
if you're curious about how I was
brought up how I know about the
existence of demons
and God and watch these videos here and
I'll see you there
and always remember life is short so
don't waste yours
cheers guys